[Musique]
avos ni sienne sq la manoeuvre russe n'a
pas fonctionné comme prévu
plusieurs véhicules blindés sont
remorqués
un autre est encore au bord de cette
route l'une des voies d'accès principale
à la ville par lesquelles les soldats
russes ont décidé d'attaquer
vitaly a participé à la bataille on les
a tapé près du pont boom là-bas boom est
assez vite en était fini de leur colonne
l'ukraine était à nous est à nous et
sera nous ils n'ont rien à faire ici
pendant trois jours les soldats russes
ont pris position dans les maisons du
quartier
il dit lui-même laissé leur reste je
vais vous montrer
ça c'est leur ration c'est écrit armées
russes
ramon était alors dans le sous sol de
son voisin une fois revenu chez lui il a
découvert que les russes n'était pas
parti les mains vides
il était chez moi ils ont bu manger ils
ont tout retourné les affaires des
enfants les miennes il devait chercher
de l'argent de l'or j'en sais rien en
tout cas ils ont volé mais antidouleur
mon parfum et de l'alcool ils ont pris
mes outils mais clé à molette la clé en
croix pour la voiture et tous les outils
électriques il y avait des affaires de
ses soldats rejette tout jeter chapeau
t-shirt quand ils ont changé de
vêtements car les miens ont disparu mais
restent les plus chaudes ils doivent
encore les porter car ce n'est plus là
ces gens là méritent d'être tué comme
itunes aux enfants
son voisin de 91 rumine encore
ils ont roulé pour se mettre dans la
cour
la porte est cassé et là aussi je
n'aurais pas adressé la parole car je
n'ai rien à dire à ces gens là
à l'entrée de la ville sergei s'est
barricadé
je me sens mieux depuis qu'on a mis ses
sacs de sable j'ai construit ça dès les
premiers jours c'est important
la nuit il dort encore au sous sol de sa
maison le danger est toujours là
apparemment ils sont encore dans le coin
puisque il y a quelques jours plusieurs
soldats russes qui rôde et ont été
capturés par les nôtres dans le coin
[Musique]
c'est probable qu'il soit encore dans
les bois oui donc on ne sort jamais le
soir car c'est dangereux on sait qu'ils
peuvent s'introduire dans les maisons
pour chercher de la nourriture et des
vêtements aux syndicats
ils réfléchissent à mettre sa femme et
ses enfants à l'abri à l'étranger
ici tous savent que l'armée russe
essayera de revenir alors vos initiales
ce que se tient prête
aux avant postes le maire de 32 ans
jeune entrepreneur avant son élection
ils se forment désormais à la tactique
militaire
on a fait sauter les ponts mais on sait
que l'ennemi peut traverser la rivière
alors avec des entrepreneurs on a creusé
de ce côté de la rivière effet une digue
20 heures seulement avant que les mines
approche de la ville pour que les tanks
il est blindé ne passe pas
il s'en serait bien passé mais savent
ils présentent un intérêt stratégique
si mikko life au sud fait sauter ses
ponts il n'y a pas d'autres routes pour
aller au dessin ou à kiev la capitale
seulement par notre ville donc on se
prépare à revoir l'ennemi la deuxième
centrale nucléaire la plus puissante du
pays est également à 30 km le maire
s'est toutefois qu'il peut compter sur
un avantage décisif nous n'avons aucun
ennemi en ville aujourd'hui nous n'avons
plus aucune disons vieilles querelles ou
de désaccord aujourd'hui nous sommes
tous main dans la main pour nous
défendre ces barricades que vous voyez
ont été construites en partie par mes
adjoints par des producteurs de lait des
boulangers tout le monde s'y met
beaucoup de civils sont devenus
combattants
à l'image de ce patron de bistrot fier
de son café moulu maison et de son
engagement
il n'y a pas de plus grande motivation
que de défendre ce que vous aimez ce que
vous avez construit
les soldats russes eux ont une
motivation matérielle pour beaucoup il
s'engage et se bat pour l'argent donc
mentalement forcément ils sont plus
faibles que nous qui défendons notre
terre
lui en a conscience il est toujours plus
facile de se battre lorsque l'on sait
pourquoi